what do you think beliefs are in
themselves can become reality
i mean so you've now adapted the
in this little bit of a conversation
adapted the
metaphysician view of reality which is
the physics yes
but you know we humans kind of operate
in the space of ideas
very much so like we've kind of in the
collective intelligence of human beings
have come up with a set of ideas that
persist in the minds of these many
people and they become quite
strong and powerful like in terms of
like impact on our lives
they can have sometimes more impact than
this table does than the physics yeah
and in that sense is is there some sense
in which our beliefs are reality
even if they're not connected to physics
yes even if they're not real
yeah even if okay so yes absolutely so
um
our beliefs are tremendously they uh
they create social effects
absolutely um there was a belief that
i'm going to use this example there was
a belief back in the day and we're
talking about when i say back in the day
i'm a historian so i'm talking about
like a thousand years ago
right that women had no souls okay so
look i don't know if
human beings have souls i can tell you
this though that a human beings have
souls probably
animals do too that's my own personal
belief that's not a professor belief
there
um but there was this belief among the
catholic
uh magisterium which is runs europe
that women had no souls so they had to
have this big meaning about it you know
did women have souls
but that belief had consequences for
women
i mean women were treated and have been
treated
as if they didn't have souls um okay so
there's and the soul was
really the essence of the human being it
was it's the it's called the animus
right it's what
is the the essence of what is eternal
you know when
women were eternal here's another
example okay this is an example from my
own research
all right so there in the catholic
tradition there's this idea
of purgatory hell and heaven
and these are three destinations that
people can go to
when they die and if you're great you go
to heaven automatically and you're
considered a saint
if you're okay you go to purgatory right
and you suffer for a time and then get
back into heaven
um if you're terrible you go to hell
right okay well there was a
place that the catholics determined and
this
this was a belief for a long time like a
thousand years
or more and it was called limbo all
right
and limbo comes from the latin limbus
and it means edge
and it was either on the edge of hell or
on the edge of heaven
no one really could determine which it
was no historians are like well this
person says it was
on the edge of heaven well listen um
this was a terrible
first of all there is no limbo anymore
in 2007
um benedict the then pope got rid of the
idea
that there was limbo okay so catholics
kind of went crazy because they didn't
really know they forgot that limbo
existed and they thought it was
purgatory
and they said how could you get rid of
purgatory but actually he just got rid
of this idea of limbo oh so that's a
distinct
thing from purgatory it was by the way
people should know they have a book on
purgatory that came before your
uh american cosmic yes i wrote a book on
purgatory yeah
anyway so limbo is a distinct thing from
purgatory yeah
and the the types of people who go
to limbo happen to be virtuous pagans
okay like socrates or somebody like that
um
and children who weren't baptized so
think of this
think of for thou like more than a
thousand years
mothers and fathers gave birth to babies
who weren't baptized
and couldn't be buried with their family
in these
burial and you know they then they
couldn't be reunited with them in heaven
think of the pain and suffering that
that caused and that was
nothing limbo's nothing yet the belief
in it
caused untold suffering and that's just
a small example
and that was as real to them it was
absolutely real
i mean the effects were real let's put
it that way the place itself
not real but the families themselves do
you think they've really believed it
they totally believed it the table is
real yes
i've read but listen we have trigger
warnings today
right so don't read this it's gonna make
you upset okay
history primary sources no trigger
warnings okay
so you're going through like you know
somebody's diary from
1400 and you hear the suffering and pain
that they went through
there were times in my research where
i'd have to put
my primary source down you know and just
basically go outside and take a walk
because it was so horrific i knew it was
true because they wouldn't write
something you know they're not gonna
write in their diary something that's
not true and it was horrible so yes
these people went through
untold suffering for nothing for you
know because they had an erroneous
belief
but they didn't know it was erroneous so
it's real to them yeah
you